[Music]
you have a movie coming out later this
year
hillbilly elegy for Netflix exactly
which also have a theatrical run as well
we don't have a date yet but for people
that aren't familiar with it can you say
what it's about
it's a memoir written by JD Vance it was
a best-seller for nearly two years and
it's about a guy from the Rust Belt Ohio
whose family came from from Appalachia
Jackson Kentucky and it's the sort of
the collision between his chaotic
childhood and and sort of the the way in
which that informed his his life and his
thinking and and his and his potential
and which was ultimately he graduated
from from from Yale Law School before he
wrote this book and he's going on to do
other things and so it's it's it's
really a you know it's it's a it's a
story of transformation and while it
focuses on that culture a group of
people that I really really relate to
given my own family background and
history from and and my wife's as well
it's it really is about being your best
self finding strength in your heritage
and the lessons that you learn but also
recognizing the the hurdles that some of
that might represent as well and and and
learning how to grow beyond it so it's
just you know it's a it's a self
actualization story it's it's it's
powerful Glenn Close is stunning your
cast is ridiculous Amy Adams just kills
it and then we have newcomers playing
both the younger and older JD Vance who
did a you know a great job as well
Haley Bennett's in and she's terrific
it's a it was a just a really great
performance opportunity probably the
best one that I've had in that regard
since maybe frost/nixon her beautiful
mind oh you guys aiming for maybe like
the Toronto Film Festival with it I
don't know I really don't know
Netflix is marketing plans and because I
just finished we finished shooting
editing now as I was doing as I've been
doing rebuilding
paradise I've been sort of dividing my
time between hillbilly ology editing
rooms got a few pickups to do and then
we'll see